comme chaque année la mopa l'association
des membres de l'ordre des palmes
académiques récompense les lauréats du
concours défense et illustration de la
langue française
les cinquante cinq meilleurs élèves de
l'académie de la réunion se voit
distingué des récompenses départementale
trois autres jeunes réunionnais sont
lauréats du concours national il ici ta
valeur ton enthousiaste pour la langue
française
j'espère que cet enthousiasme l'asp
accompagnera nous avons la grande chance
de surcroît cette année d'avoir des
lauréats nationaux c'est à dire des gens
qui ont été reconnus par un jury
national
et comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure la
première fois il ya très longtemps
nous avons eu 1 n'aurait lauréat
national nous avons eu deux lauréats
nationale une fois et nous voilà avec
trois lauréats
je ne sais pas si c'est un signe de la
progression de la réunion toute entière
mais je suis je suis très très très
tenté de le voir là dedans à symbole du
réel travail que nous faisons à
l'éducation nationale ici et de la
progression magnifique de voilà de nos
écoles de nos lycées de nos collèges
trois prix ont été créés pour les
participants des écoles élémentaires des
collèges des lycées et des universités
il s'agit du prix d'expression écrite de
la langue française du prime aux
passants de la jeune nouvelle et du prix
de la jeune poésie qui élit balasy s'est
vu récompensé du premier prix de la
jeune poésie pour son poème à la vie à
la mort sa palette une fleur et elle a
connu plusieurs péripéties dont dont le
mauvais temps et tout est eux il ya
toutefois sa personne tu viens larose et
malgré le temps et eux et à la fin quand
l'homme urbain elle se retrouve sur la
tombe de cette personne
qu'est ce qui t'as inspiré ce poème bon
bah en fait c'est venu tout seul mais
c'est en fait aux convois de fleurs on
voit plutôt sa beauté et pas quand elles
passent par la fifa le prix d'honneur du
département de la réunion a été décerné
à zoé duprat élève en classe de
troisième au collège de l'étang saint
paul c'est vraiment avec beaucoup de
satisfaction que on se rend de plus en
plus compte qu'on a des pépites à l'île
de la réunion et c'est avec beaucoup de
plaisir pour continuera vraiment à les
guider à les encadrer à les amener vers
l'excellence c'est une grande
satisfaction de voir que à la réunion
voilà on a des petits réunionnais qui
s'accrochent et qui souhaitent vraiment
s'en sortir et à travers la langue
française mettre en avant notre culture
notre façon de vivre et d'être est
vraiment cet ensemble qui fait que tous
ensemble au niveau de nos cultures au
niveau de nos traditions nous formons 7
da l'île de la réunion et la langue
française nous permet bien sûr de mettre
en avant tout le potentiel potentialités
à l'est de la réunion
nos jeunes talents littéraires ont été
récompensés tout au long de cette remise
de prix des auteurs en devenir qui déjà
font la défense et la promotion de la
langue et de la culture française